I am now seeing this phenomenon of
giving porn stars rewards Mia Khalifa
was a huge porn star I don't know much
about it all I know is that this woman
was huge and I've seen her go on podcast
after podcast after podcast talking
about exploited she was and how she
really regrets her decisions then this
woman comes out with an only fan how on
Earth can you be exploited and regret
your decisions while also being on only
fans it sounds like you were just bad at
negotiating a good deal now this woman
is being taken seriously as an actual
runway model how insulting is it to the
real models that represent grace and
beauty that we have a tatted up porn
star on runways this is a disgrace if I
was a woman that took modeling seriously
and broke my back to become a model I
would be absolutely offended in
protesting that a post-wall porn star is
now beating me for a gig this is
ridiculous we need to stop catering to
women and cater to men that is not what
men want or want to see a tatted up porn
star maybe for the night but when I
think of a model I think of beauty and
elegance and not this nonsense that
they're pushing today Giorgio says you
are not a model well no [__] Giorgio
obviously she's not so I would ask
whoever's in charge of the modeling
industry it's not an industry I know
much about
um I thought that models were supposed
to be beautiful and represent the most
beautiful women in society why on Earth
do you have a tatted up porn star up
there this is pandering and catering and
us women are sick of being sold a dream
we are sick of being pandered to and at
some point us women need to get together
and tell them we are tired